hello
welcome to uh game spot plays
i'm here with jake decker what's up
what's up we're playing mirrors edge
catalyst
uh this is in uh closed beta so we got
an early copy
um
today this morning i've played about two
hours or so but uh it's super fun we're
gonna take a look at it right now
look at that city look at it
um yeah so this is fairly early on you
know it's just a little taste of this
upcoming game
um but yeah here we go uh so
we got ourselves a nice little map here
um i did do the tutorial uh which had a
lot of stories cinematics which are
actually really awesome but i thought
we'd just get right into it and show off
what you actually do in this open world
so so about how much have you played so
far yeah like i'd say it was like
an hour and a half
just about
okay um so yeah there's you know uh just
let's get back in here uh basic stuff
you know you you know you get upgrade
points for movement combat and gear here
uh i've i've spent two so far one of
what so i've heard uh one of the um
important ones
is the skill roll which is it really
like
you you'd almost want this to be
a given uh already because it's it keeps
the
the movement rolling so to speak yeah i
feel like without that
you know you take a big fall and you're
just kind of
you're stopped
right um
and then there's you know there's combat
stuff i'll show some of that off uh i
haven't seen any like
uh
enemies in the open world yet i imagine
that's something that you probably
encounter uh on a regular basis um
and you get gear stuff here but yeah
let's get back into it now are those
locked in there because this is a beta
are they locked because you haven't
unlocked them yet like do you know
approximately how much you can unlock i
don't i really don't yet i imagine it's
only a
small amount
um you know so there's the roll so yeah
sooner earlier you just get like a um
prior to that you just get like a uh
you just kind of cushion your fall but
you don't you don't get to retain your
your momentum
um it's really kind of jarring but
anyways let's do a little side quest
here
um how big is the map
it's big but there is only so much i get
to enjoy which is probably like here
okay i tried to like i was i tried to go
over here and you know there's
like this street just doesn't let you
continue uh there's there's nothing you
can parkour off of to get that far does
it look like just because it's a beta
it's closed yeah absolutely there were
some really obvious um
uh areas that were like oh okay this is
maybe maybe a skill will uh help me
continue
ooh the audio seems a little yeah it's
kind of
on the gameplay audio
this is okay now okay let's see let's
talk to nomad here
he just hangs out on buildings right
there there she is in the flesh in my
clothes even
thanks for looking after them
how have you been well you know living
surviving
i missed you
don't crush
so what do you need help with it's the
outcast in greylands they're setting up
a comm system to warn about casecrates
but they need control chips which can be
found in all com relay boxes
control chips relay boxes okay
by ripping those chips you mess things
up for allcom and help the outcast at
the same time can you do it
sure
you know me
always helping those in need you can
play indifferent but i know why you got
locked up
yeah i was stupid where can i find these
boxes
not far from here i'll mark them for you
it's quite the exposition for finding
boxes oh yeah
definitely
all right
oh we're back here again
yeah so early on in the beginning of
this
i got the first trip
great the next relay box should be close
um
yeah earlier i i basically broke out of
prison i should warn you faith there are
more cases
yeah and they look like there's that
like tutorial section telling me how to
like
get around things
uh more or less this group so they're
called like runners right is this group
you're with
um you probably know more about the
story than i it's like what's like the
setup here or actually we'll hear these
guys here we go
tell us the setup yeah the watermark on
this beta is really annoying sorry about
that yeah it was like in his that's
around
so the combat i was really enjoying you
get to like throw dudes off
um environmental
objects and into other enemies it's
pretty fun and what it's about right is
the momentum like the faster you're
going the quicker you can take down
enemies exactly there's a those three
bottom left uh those are my head like my
health bar and then the one to the right
is like uh my speed gang and i get yeah
i get first with it all right let's kick
this guy's butt
so like this here is going to be a
little bit tougher since there's no
momentum you got right
but i can still get momentum so i can do
things like this like
oh no uh my strong attack is is triangle
we're playing on ps4 by the way and i
can
basically use the environment hopefully
i can knock him into like
there we go bam so you do stuff like
that like off you know off buildings
other guys oh wait what was i supposed
to do
i'm sorry
oh it's teaching me more stuff oh she
just killed your teacher
so your objective is still to defeat
them that's weird that you failed
i think they wanted me to try that
let's watch this
okay i'll do this one this is going
oh
almost almost i can do like a cool like
high jump and then
land into him
i'm not there
what's up
all right okay i have to feed him that
time okay yeah that box
just pulled another chip
excellent this will make a difference i
promise you
by the way did you talk to dogan yet
yeah that was like that was huge about
the last game i think that's what
i loved about it was just how like when
you start out you're not very good and
you're kind of gonna suck but after a
couple hours you start to really
understand how to move efficiently
throughout the throughout the world
right it's all about like keeping that
moment oh damn it as i do that
is that a runner
what have we got we might need backup
there's a preacher you do like that
like that
again
oh come on
i want to knock them into each other
have you confronted anyone with guns yet
uh no no definitely not
but that's one thing i think i remember
reading like if you are at full speed
bullets like you basically dodge bullets
um
but if you're going slower bullets can
hurt you and in the previous games you
could or in the last game you could
actually use a gun but this they took it
away
which i think is good because
gun play was like clunky and it was kind
of like why am i doing this yeah
but i'm curious if like
later in the game people are going to
want guns
it's trying to juke you oh
crack this is a good sound
i could speed up the bodies but
another one
got another one
great yes if you guys have any questions
be sure to
put them in the uh
in the chat and uh jake here will do his
best to read them yeah i'm looking at
most people just
commenting on the game
in my amazing skills
the world looks like if apple had
it's just all white
yeah right
i mean that's how it was the other one
too but
so do you know much about the story like
they i looked into them yeah yeah um so
i didn't play it a whole lot of the
first i think i got about more than
halfway through um
but basically runners basically deliver
messages in this sort of dystopian
future
um and
i'm assuming catalyst is sort of about
the sort of the actions that kind of set
in this uprising yeah uh that ignite it
i guess um but to be honest i haven't
really been keeping up too much with
this i think i've i played it at e3
cool um it was very early and we were
condensed to a very small area um it
looks like this you already have more
yeah yeah it's there
this one's a big advocate of the open
world right like oh shoot
is there any multiplayer in this beta i
have no idea uh was there any
multiplayer in the original there wasn't
but i know there's like uh time trials
and stuff that you can set but i got the
last one betas are always so weird when
they're single
what's happening
k-sec is happening
i had enough of this crap in prison
don't get involved
i told you this is happening all the
time go ahead yeah um that's so that's
like my my runner vision more or less i
think it's called something else but
that's a right click on this stick and
it kind of gives me a nice waypoint
for parkour the best route for
parkouring hardcore parkour that's
exactly right
hey over here
dude i'm all about the the jump and then
the uh the attack down
i want to see that so this is what this
is what i want to show you guys what
it's like when you die um
i'm glad we got this out of the way
these and actually these loading uh
times when you die are
embarrassingly painful for me
it's like all right
i suck
yeah especially after all that momentum
and then
yeah okay
i had enough of this crap in prison
the voice acting has been actually
really great
um
like really engaging
for someone who has no idea what the
story is about i heard there wasn't much
of a story in the first one um but
i'm like i cool i want to know more
about what's going on
so do you know
if uh
dicey plans to like vr fight this i was
thinking about the vr at nature of this
and how
how cool i think it could actually turn
out
i feel like a lot of people get sick
yeah that's then that's that's how most
of them are yeah and that's possible um
but yeah i mean i feel like you could do
it because a lot of me wants to keep
running straight and look around me you
know like yeah um
the response of this of the look stick
is a little um
slow like i feel like just you know the
essence of vr like you could
really get a grasp of like your
environment further i'm gonna set you
straight oh yeah
prove it
make your move blue man nemo42 wants to
know if uh will you be able to design
your own course course mode that lets
you move assets i don't think you can
move assets but i know you can design
your own courses basically routes and
then you can upload them and have other
people test them out oh wow
um but i could be wrong about moving
assets but i'm pretty sure you can i'm
pretty sure you're kind of confined to
the
the geography of the world in order to
create those great those uh
races um
but that that actually seems like a
pretty cool idea of
you're okay just making a run and you're
like all right i want to see if other
people can do this faster than me and
just
put it online
i'll touch on that in a second i i had
like a
side quest in the opening world that was
like that like a race say that like it's
a bad thing
keep looking for those relay boxes
around the city faith don't really help
the outcast
okay now we need that first handful of
chips to deliver disgusting
there's a dead drop with the marker on
your map
um yeah so in this open world we'll do
some side missions and objectives but
one of them ah dang it sorry one of them
was um
like yeah just like a basic like
delivery race and upon completing it
it's you know ranked me with other
actual people who have this uh open beta
okay which isn't a lot damn it i'm
sucking
um it's hard to talk and do this but um
yeah not many people but um yeah it was
cool it was like all right that's fun i
can see myself doing that again i'm
sorry i'm not paying attention
the controls
at least from what i remember is so like
sort of right bumper i guess r1 is to go
up and
the trigger is or right trigger is to go
underneath things
um or is it different because that's the
left trigger is uh slide
and like the roll
okay and then jump is uh
l1 okay yeah so it is like the other
ones where like all your
sort of upward moment mobility things
are
r1 and then
downward mobility or r2 right right
where's the drum
slight change of plans they want to use
another dead drop nearby and there's a
bunch of patrols between you and there
yeah a lot of people are pointing out
that
if you get motion sickness from vr this
is gonna definitely oh yeah there's
definitely gonna do you in and i'm
and other people in the office uh
definitely have have said
they get motion sickness i i don't i
haven't been getting it as much
dude i'm sorry i'm sucking so bad right
now it's gonna write talk um but
yeah this would definitely be one that
right there when you do that roll that
would
that would oh that would totally do it
yeah this would this would probably be
like all right an hour in i'm doing vr
of this
if you stop or make too many mistakes
you won't make it
sick do it
yeah
i feel like you should have fallen over
with that hit though
i want to do a wall run and knock them
out
oh come on
oh i was i had to just run through these
guys i'm sorry i'm not paying attention
let's do it again
i just want to like use cool moves
parkour moves on these guys and break
their helmets
uh nemo asks have you found like
multiple routes to complete
like the similar objectives uh does it
seem like there's an open sort of level
design oh absolutely um
like it was funny looking at all the
times of other people um
one of the or the top uh time was like
half of the second place guy
which and they mentioned like oh you can
develop your like look for your own
routes
to you know cutting
the time uh yourself
man there must be a nightmare to sort of
design
something like that yeah
oh that was sick
yeah again i'm sorry if i find one
i just gotta keep going huh yeah just
keep moving don't let them catch you
you'll never catch me
yeah oh
tomorrow
you too huh
damn that's fun
so this is always nice to change it up
too like i like this you know this
up paste
style
let's do it
one more
i want to push you off let me do it
thanks uh it wasn't even that far of a
drop
all right later
ah
rats
do we know the frame rates for these
games
uh this it looks pretty smooth yeah it
looks pretty smooth like i couldn't tell
you what it is i wouldn't say it's like
a perfect 60 i cut scenes have been
actually major uh that
have noticed um especially in the beta
we had like pc footage uh earlier that
was having the same issue but you know
it's better you can only hope
yeah from what i can tell
um it doesn't look it doesn't look like
30. um but i i don't know if it hits 60.
it looks like it's faster than or uh
it's got a higher firmware than 30.
right i'd say it's it's definitely not
six years
oh this one was tough i was doing this
by myself
so i was like trying to do some
exploring and it's really fun to like
run into it run to a point where you
don't know what like you know you have
these runs and then they'll end and be
like what's my next plan of action as
you're like hanging
on a side of a building
uh
so like what i'm trying to say it's just
the open world is it seems really fun to
explore
hitting those rolls is so satisfying it
actually really is
yeah it's funny they don't give it to
you early on
oh
oh
i was close i wasn't paying attention
again are you supposed to interact right
there with that
or was i supposed to hit that circle
spot
i think i'm supposed to just get to that
area i don't know
i've been pulling chips i guess that's i
don't know we'll just do it again
but yeah well after we'll just we do
this mission i'll show you some of the
um
uh other things you can do in the open
world like um you have you know like
like a base um
where your
group lies and you get to go back and
the runners the runners i don't think
they have another name
they might
oh they got a checkpoint you just punch
it and then you get what you need
oh there's a collectible there i missed
oh well you can't break the momentum you
can't do it look at this
yeah it's it's and that's that's what
also keeps that bar bottom uh what they
call it again oh shh
i was gonna point it out but i figured
you had some other way you're gonna get
up there well it just leads you to
believe it sometimes
um what does that look like it's like
your runner focus um you know you want
to keep that up oh yes and the second
you lose speed it goes down oh really
yeah so it's like a drive to have those
runs
um fluid
one thing with uh the first mirror's
edge was all the red objects were sort
of like already in the world
um so you just usually follow the red
objects and it's like in this it's
it's more so runner vision that turns
things right
oh
it's that it's that ladder you gotta hit
that light it's that dumb ass ladder i
can't hit my bad all right
let me get my focus on i apologize
uh
goob is wondering how long the load
times have been well they've been this
this is they've been pretty long
these are the load times for
um sometimes they're not they're not as
long depending on what you're doing but
deaths and um
uh
reloading a checkpoint have been about
this long
did we get a pc
version a pcb in or we just we just get
consoles
i i know of an xbox and a ps4 i don't
know if pc okay all right i got this
all right hit that roll
nice nice
don't even do oh no no
god
it's all right that's all right
there we go this is it
oh
yeah there we go two seconds jesus
christ
we would i would have just canceled the
stream
just quickly let's quit my yeah quit my
job
what are those
grid leak are they just like
maps basically
i there's a bunch of different types of
collectibles you can get
uh i believe that's what those are i'm
not quite sure said something on the
left there grid leaks
pick up another one and see what says
that watermark is so annoying
oh it's just so it's xp and then it's
just like
in a in a given area there's there's a
certain amount so it seemed like there
was like 15.
yeah the watermark is atrocious like i
understand making you know the
notification of having a beta but you
know ruin ruin a corner of the screen
not the entire
entirety of it
um all right cool i think that was the
end of the mission
let's take a look at what we can do here
so we i can head back to base here and
show you what's there there's not a
whole lot i imagine we'll just kind of
end up there but the layer
you know you got your delivery you got
different types of dashes i dash i
haven't done yet
um billboards billboards are like
collectibles as well why don't we go
and try this because i haven't done that
yet
um
so here's the city and so the christine
white the runner vision is gonna show
you like the best route like it's gonna
highlight like
the objects you should be like running
on and like doing all that sort of stuff
to get there sure and if you even look
at it it kind of
has these really jagged uh waypoints
that are definitely like
in the form of a route um but what's
funny enough is like i've
right after that when i got into open
world i was like all right let me see if
i can go here
and
this is a bad example but there's one
time where it just
because i'm i'm assuming the beta has
been locking this off but it just like
stopped into a wall all right
uh so we got an upgrade point we want to
upgrade here jake
uh i'm all for movement to be honest
okay i agree i want to keep that
movement going
right raise your legs while in the air
all right all right
oh that's kind of cool
l1l2
uh
whoa
r1
180 degrees oh you can do it while walt
that's pretty cool
oh that's key
well what do we have in a combat though
okay it could be some sick
damage no wait what was this
back that's not the one i want to move
yeah like
oh get
like a combo light attack
take an extra hit you can look at some
of these other these these long tier
ones
uh
it's damaged
yeah these these appear to be locked
locked
gear
so this is actually when i unlocked it
it showed me all the cool stuff that you
can do in the city okay that was viable
uh what
i'd say i say the quick turn
yeah
well
i say either quick turn or coil
what's chat say
what do you guys think quick turn or
coil or something completely different
first person just respond
check check check
chat chat
oh we have a better
delay i think
okay
someone's installing rocket league
though
quick turn he says quick turn
you hit it first all right
that was an r what is that hold on turn
around what is that is that a person
yes she
is that she's a little weird
a little cat tonic here
oh i think i got this
so you see people scatter around and she
gave me um you know she's just kind of
lurking up here she gave me a delivery
run that i think i feel like she's not
dressed to be on a rooftop she looks
like she's going to like a bar you know
what i agree with you but what's
interesting is like every rooftop is
actually pretty
nice that's true
which is oddly like it looks like it's
been cleaned yeah
she's cool though all right
uh if you say she's cool
take my word for it all right so let's
see which way we go is it back here
what's it telling you it's telling me to
go through the solar panel
ah there we go there it is
so should we uh try a quick turn
actually just see if i can do it off a
wall yeah so i think it was right bumper
right or r1 r1
so wall yeah okay
vertical wall run
that you're probably just going to run
up that you probably need a better wall
oh it's a little bit of pipe it's a pipe
cool that's actually really helpful
do uh run up the wall for it like see so
you can get a couple steps up the wall
now do it yeah there we go that's cool
that's cool that's helpful i'm sure all
right let's continue
see i don't know why okay there's
something to say about that it like i
hit the slide and the slide is the same
as the roll
and so i guess i'm holding maybe slide
too much because then it continues into
a roll which is not what i want to do
and then next thing i know i'm off a
building
people are very curious about vr
in this game which one am i going again
yeah the role would be it could be very
motion sickness
i did that too early
uh you're getting a little orb
orb action or life
see the pipes always slow you down
there's nothing you can do about that
it seems like the same with ladders it
seems like the
just don't do conventional things in
this right right if you see a sidewall
you could run up and then like go for it
because pipes are pretty conventional
you know like i climb them all the time
right me too that's how i get home every
day that's how i commute yeah
am i just going back to my base i guess
oh sometimes the story's not always open
you show them the base she's always
busting over her home base door she's
like i always want this unlocked what
are you guys doing
that's the eighth block we've gone
through this week
please
we can't afford our operation if you
burn through locks this pad right
oh wait
did i
didn't i see it go somewhere else uh
i looked
away it looked like it was
dude i swear the path just went into the
wall wait what
did the
that took
whatever all right let's do
this
no
back in the game this sounds like a
story let's do a mission i'd rather do
that actually right now whoopsies
let's just climb all these huh
nope
so i first came in oh so this was a way
where like it it wanted me i was trying
to get into like this other side of the
city i imagine like over here
and it
it just the waypoint just went right
across and i was like
so it's like a subway so i immediately
jumped and just got hit by a train i was
like all right i guess i remember that
happening in the first one yeah oh come
on um
jc wishma says that i think that's how
you pronounce it says a slide you just
tap it to slide and you hold it to roll
right
yeah i apologize everyone's probably
grinding their teeth at me playing but
um again i'm only like two hours in and
you didn't play the first one no no one
seems to be
what seems pretty cool about it giving
you tips
oh it's just someone sleeping oh no
just sprinting around in their house so
this is like your like little home base
um
there's like people working out doing
wall runs and stuff let's watch
it's time to show you who's the new boss
boom thanks that's exactly what i did
am i interrupting something no we're
done i won
this game has no damn logic you'll get
used to it faith used to be me all the
time still could
you had a run for me
i do
on
on
elysium labs
high profile data grab very good script
an elysium data grab
you think she's ready how about you get
off my case you're going with her
i can take care of myself just fine noah
like last time you go in alone but i
want icarus on watch
look they are very protective about this
data
so there's no margin for error you
understand
and so what do i get for babysitting
a third of the script
or
i give it to aisha and caleb
your call
all right
i'll see you there faith
oh and uh
don't get lost oh
go
you don't want him to beat you there
i immediately fall off a building
but i won't because i'm super good
out the window no problem
the the framerate in that cutscene
wasn't too bad no it wasn't it wasn't
because
when mary went to go play and she was
like showing some of the footage of the
cutscenes look yeah really rough like
they looked great but just frame rate
would like dip well below 30.
yeah and granted it was pc so you know
which tends to have variable frame rate
more so sometimes but yeah even even on
uh ps4
oh shoot that's a roll i always forget
about that
whoops
oh nice
thanks if you guys have any questions
feel free to drop them in the chat
oh what i hit it
back in the game
i accept
i accept this mission oh cool guy
whoa nice roll
why
i found an open window for you
easy way inside
that doesn't sound right
is there security really that lacks
who knows do you think those are like
advanced sunglasses or do you think he's
just wearing sunglasses at night i think
he's just really dumb
he thinks he's cool go ahead
prove it
wrong is it nighttime yeah basically
pretty much
no white
that's weird
all right let's find an open oh
wait okay
her jumping skills are insane i wish i
had them
yeah look at that
like get off
the zip line and it shot me off maybe i
like i think i like jumped off the wall
i should have just not done anything
all right
i'm super good
um it's just sometimes with the zip
lines uh
i've noticed like though like they they
asked to my
experience they like don't
automatically kick you off like i've had
a couple times i've if i didn't get off
like by my doing it send me somewhere oh
yeah but i guess this one you just
had to let it let it happen
yeah okay
that's all
let's sneak into this building she
climbs pretty slow yeah she does
i mean that's probably an upgrade
all right this is a drop i can't really
tell yeah
the sound effects are really awesome
like just the sound of her like midnight
oil
pants
oh i know what you mean i also like oh
this is this is me but i love it when
you can look down and see her see your
feet yeah that's a that's i love it like
portal and stuff yeah portal i know like
the halo games always do it but like
call of duty you're just a floating gun
yeah exactly
i mean it's not a huge deal but it's
always a nice touch yeah
good this place is just perfect
it's perfectly designed
am i trying to like avoid
peeps
god imagine having an office meeting in
here
it's green
we need money
gotta keep it green just come out of
there just get eyes fried
can i make this jump yeah oh yeah you
can you gotta you gotta get some i just
my
depth is wrong sometimes yep
oh that's sick
all right up that wall i can do it
i'm getting
everything
do you think they're actually why do you
think they painted them i think they
painted them yeah i think so too
spray paint them
occupies the top floors fastest way to
use the elevators probably reaching here
but
and uh there's this episode of spongebob
where they go to the future and
everything is painted everything else
everything is chrome future and like
a little a little plant sprouts up and
just the whole team comes over pulls out
of chrome that's right
yeah he sprays paint so i imagine it is
in this except white exactly except for
this place like now we're going to use
green wait hold on help me out here i'm
not getting any more paths uh
i think i think drop down here yeah i
think so
ah dang it
no
i was just here
i didn't see where the the runner vision
offline okay so
go
back to yeah go back into that room
i'm gonna guess you can get up there
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm
done yep
uh
flaming teddy gamer wants to know if my
watch come on what if merc has been
shown yet in this demo i'm guessing this
character uh yeah i believe so i was
reading a little bit of wikipedia story
um no i don't there hasn't been much
about him was he like the main villain i
guess
honestly i don't remember
yeah
um but as of yet the answer is no
oh man there's a wall run
damn dang
oh i think you can climb that though oh
yeah
no i don't know if i can
try yeah that way there you go
oh i thought you missed that for a
second so did i jake
oh this is nice
this is tight
oh man can you imagine doing this vr and
like the falling in vr would be too much
yeah
oh man can you imagine like missing a
ledge
yeah oh i was gonna say look down again
while you're oh
that's all right we'll do it again
i'll probably fail this
i was gonna say that but i was kind of
thinking it
all right
let's do this
oh this is where my 180 move could have
been really cool you know i did that oh
one go
so are you supposed to remain undetected
that's what i'm gathering right now
ready to go because i would have been
sick to jump on that swing and oh yeah
you're going up and over we're doing
something to get through there we're
doing some kind of data mining right
we're like sneaking in and getting some
data
so you probably shouldn't kick the [ __ ]
out of
right even though i'd love to
throw some dude off
i mean if i kill them both at the same
time then they don't sound alarm and
we're fine
just slide in feet first
feeling sick
needs more sliding she's like just like
just grease up
just slide through the slide through
everything
i'm finishing this
damn right all right
boring
next
oh yeah
oh
oh
oh [ __ ] sorry
oh yeah
document
yep
two out of seven
yeah i got one earlier i was pretty
happy about that
can you read it
that's a good question i haven't um i
haven't looked into that i could
probably look at twitter right now why
not maybe we'll see what a document
entails
probably i'll try just to collect no
there we go hot dog
oh of course
oh no bad wasn't the guy was the guy
yeah this is the dude who's like showing
up
or is he showing off no that's not
excuse me
i don't really care that guy's got or
that guy's got sunglasses
right
oh we're not gonna do that
but you can't just just read it on the
street
yeah that's kind of what i was thinking
mongoose how batman gets into vents so
he just kind of like kicks him open
grabs the top and just slides in yeah
whatever
i was hoping i could
do that in one go after we just talked
about it
i will push him off a building
he's kind of a jerk now but i better
redeem himself or
or or he's playing both sides that's
right
oh man i think we've cracked the case i
think so not that it's ever a trope or
anything
where am i going i have a feeling it's
over here somewhere
what is that in the center is that like
a
map of some that's kind of cool some
augmented reality
let's get closely here oh yeah look at
that oh yeah
oh yeah this is nice
and a tree just wait there for tomorrow
and they have their meeting
uh can i help you
no that's not right
what do you see here you see any any
paths
c4m says this is what i imagine
ubisoft's head offices to look like but
with loads of bugs everywhere
actual bugs
um
do you see anything
up here uh
maybe yeah grab onto that light see if
you can get onto that light and oh
i don't know if this is from the
original but like so i use r2 trigger to
like
pick up my speed and i like i don't hold
on there's no sprint it's just a way of
like picking up speed like that but it's
also a dash
yeah i'm pretty sure that was um so
that's why if you see you're seeing me
like do that once a while because i
accidentally might have my stick forward
it's a way of like gaining speed i don't
know
um okay so just go up here i don't know
what to do oh you climb up on those
this works
oh that's nice oh they got some greenery
not enough but it's locked away no one
can no one can go in there
you just look at it
but
no this is where the this is where the
plant look
get me in i want to touch the plants
the plants get to watch tv
of course of course right
the future is now
special channels
3g
that's what they're on
downgrade
oh it's the floor
what's next oh oh yeah i'm getting here
i'm so getting here
oh this is where it is
no it's his
sons that's true this is too far in the
future
noah that's that douche's name plants
behind glass and glass how symbolic
scott
says
scott buttersworth butterworth yup
scott butterworth
he's watching the street fantastic
oh is this dude ruining my day
he's like
i'll screw with her path
go for it
god even the vents don't even have dust
yeah duh they've eradicated dust in this
future
oh
no now we're getting somewhere
yeah okay
this is about right
top floor yeah
uh-huh
cat scans
this way
this way
yeah
this room so you can't god i'm gang
almost a little sick of these rooms just
like
it's boring
oh here's me
it hurt we went for an elevator
okay i'm sorry
she got access in there damn right all
right her palm is a hacking card
oh
just napping on the job
oh this dude oh he's got a machete
look out
grab her ankle grab her ankle
wake up
oh classic classic awesome
jim are you napping again
hey
everything's cool
hi can i help you
do you work here i like that head turn
oh
why are they walking towards oh whoa
because she she knows how to fight wait
who's the badass in this situation
grab the phone and leave
wait
i needed my line
what was that in his hand
what
oh did he cyanide i was about to say it
oh
well guess we're getting no more
splinter cell games
and
oh exit strategy
nope
i'm sick
whoa
tight i'm loving it
all right
let's do it
whoa
snipers
damn are they firing
oh this is slow-mo yeah
bullet trails
oh
so you're so focused shield
this is this is like
the bread and butter of momentum
whoa all right where am i going
uh i'm i'm blowing it i'm blowing it
real nicely
there you go give me some bullet shield
oh man
see what you can do
oh that was sick you just grabbed does
that no this isn't right
well hey guys
oh this is picasso
zip out of here oh you're not done yet
though
faith
what is it cougar sect krueger said
the height of which you uh die is
actually like not
um
not that short
it's because it's realistic exactly it's
like it was interesting i was like wow i
was like damn that like
most games would be you know you take
some damage but no they don't they're
not very generous with it which is nice
oh i know this area
i think i'm almost home
well i wish i did that a little smoother
but you know me
figuring it out is my excuse
that was fun though
that looked cool yeah
jail and chilling on a pole still there
still there
see he's always i'm always kicking doors
it's like damn it face
so there's no way to just open a door
like if you if you're going slow and do
it we should just kick it open anyway
i don't think i don't think so it's it's
it's been i mean i've been up against
like you know just standing up against
it not like
you know running into it and it's been
the same animation i think i can't help
it
i didn't do anything wrong good to see
you too do you keep this up i swear
you'll be dead in a month oh that ends
well i got this
this isn't from here neither was the guy
who had it he died for it could be worth
enough to solve things with dogen yeah
or enough to see us dead
anything having to do with gabriel
kruger we need to stay miles away from
i'm inclined to send it back to him
did kruger see you
he saw someone
too dark to see much at all look i
thought that this would be no you didn't
think faith you never do
but i need to
figure out what to do with this in the
meantime trying to get some framework
dropped okay i already lost oh yeah
if you're not i'm back
krueger sex gone this guy
uh thank you i like how he's not wearing
sunglasses during the day
also when the sun is the most annoying
golden hours in your face
that's right so she had a sister kate in
the first one right
who like got framed for murder or
something i have to finish this uh yeah
girl over here you'll be safe in here
just stay put
what
faith i'm scared
let us go krueger you should have
cooperated dr connors
i didn't want this
mommy
what is that
that my little squirrel
is your future
this is the messiest room we've seen so
far
you see that black pepsi can it's all
black pepsi
faith i got just a thing for you
know that
where are you i got my hands on a glitch
mod which should work with your b-link
i've sent you a copy you can use it to
get through the fans at zephyr try it
out and come meet me we have a situation
position
hmm
okay is it a mannequin
you know
i was talking about everyone these are
all belly sleepers i mean i'm excited
for this person
um cool well you know that's that's a
mission uh we don't know how much time
we got left we'll go to three ish right
we got maybe seven five minutes five
minutes
um why don't we
do
a side
quest thing and call it
um
what do what are what are
the offer options so we got a dash i i
don't know i don't know what those are
things we're going to do earlier uh
delivery mission is just like a simple
uh race like i'm sure all these are like
timed and or time based with like
competitive nature for like online stuff
um they're just collectibles
was that like climb up a find a route up
to a high spot i'm guessing yeah it's
yeah exactly actually these are more
climbing based uh then parkour runs um
dashes yeah i don't know i don't know
what those are billboard
bond brunette a fragile same thing
why don't we do
let's do a dash because i don't know
what that is i like i personally would
like to see what they are about all
right
um
or should we let the chat decide what we
do sure or the chat i mean they're going
to agree with me i know it so what is it
dash delivery
billboard let's not do billboard though
billboard's it's not that great you just
i mean i mean it's it's just like it's
more of a collectible to me so we're
talking dash or delivery that's right
all right dash or delivery what are we
gonna do i'm gonna head toward dash
unless
everyone disagrees with me that's fine
um but yeah let's do that oh yeah
actually we get to see more of this base
area i'm sure like
oh dang we got two dashes we got three
dashes we're doing dash
so that 180 move we unlocked it actually
just is like
it's always use it on the ground it's
all the time it's everywhere i go now
which i like it follows you ooh this is
nice
some some rays coming in
the city i think i mentioned earlier
well then the setting and the kind of
the the
essence of it
it reminds me of like equal equilibrium
it's like yeah you're still going to be
in a perfect city and everything like
that it's um i thought the other day for
like the
tenth time
while you were away
don't
just don't talk
this is where i've seen people people be
sleeping this is early morning what the
heck
the only one up
it's because they're all out late at
night
doing runner parties and stuff can i go
over this whoops
gotta get their sleep
if your muscles aren't in peak condition
all right let's get out of here i don't
know how much time do i
yeah
uh no this is we're playing on ps4 right
now it i don't think we got um pc yeah i
don't think we have a pc code for the
beta we have an xbox one and playstation
4. so this is playstation 4.
uh
what
oh sick
okay
uh now we have no ac faith thanks so
much
first the doors then the ac
car the maintenance guy again
you're just not cut out to be a runner
no i keep forgetting to do the see if
that animation's the same for opening
doors
oh whoa some frame rate stutters
is the dash
i believe it is
logging in where did that see yes so you
even it even starts off showing you um
times and stuff like that
what are we gonna get number one well
two
looks like a couple so 42 42 seconds is
the time to beat probably won't beat it
but let's try it
fear the muffin says equilibrium is his
favorite movie that's a cool ass movie
it's pretty good
pretty good
uh master hero says the lack of grimy
textures can make a game look a little
boring sometimes i kind of think we were
going
when we were going through that mission
i think we were kind of getting that we
were like all right we've we've seen
these rooms before
yeah
it's it's it's cool it's different right
like i
i'm not gonna say i hate it i just
sometimes it's it's a little boring a
little sparse
yeah um you know you can have that same
aesthetic but you know you give me some
more objects or something i don't know
well i lost that time
move oh man
i'm that far behind this is a wall right
here
so yeah these you gotta avoid those you
know damn i was like
wow yeah
oh
new best how many stars
sick
cool on the board
well those are those are pretty quick
why don't we do um
let's try race then or not race excuse
me a um triumph
a deliverer
uh screw it let's do all these all right
all right i'll show you i want to show
everyone this stuff it's enjoyable it's
cool you get to like
the billboards at least are nice because
you know
for me like
dash so far dash and uh the delivery
they're about the same you want them as
fast as possible billboard at least
changes it up and kind of lets you like
think about all right what obstacles do
i need to jump on to um but let's see
where i imagine it being similar like
far cry climb the radio towers or
whatever
just yeah way more wait well actually
and and cooler and that far cry is like
pretty linear yeah um
oh so like this i will die if i jump
down for sure
even though that looks like a soft spot
to land though right
probably not
all right
oh what
i totally hit it
but i also suck
where am i going
okay
okay i'm not holding i keep getting sick
this is also a game that like yes i'm
obviously not doing doing hot at but man
i want to get really good at it you know
okay so this is it
so now i just have to figure out how to
get up here i think yeah
looks like a round there's a good bet
can you make that jump right here
can i make it jake
oh whoa i could almost got a little
higher
and it looks like there's another
balcony right above i don't know how
you're going to get to that though oh
was it party
i was in the life i wasn't invited let
me
i wasn't invited
they don't talk to each other
this party whatever this party sucks
and also what are what what are these
people wearing on their faces
blindfolds is this a silent disco i
thought that was a headband on that guy
right
also
they
are identical
they are triplets
and they also love talking on the phone
moving on all right i don't i don't know
if i can get up
this isn't looking good i don't know
because i this is there's oh you said
that wait i actually can't notice yeah i
did notice that that's what i was
talking about see what happens
oh okay
i think i think you cheesed that one a
little no i
oh yeah look at me go dude
yeah so these are i guess these are kind
of still pretty linear but oh no
god damn it
my bad
shoot
well quick turn is very very useful jake
good thing we got it
we got it right
uh yeah i believe that's definitely
that's the oh yeah
man i really wanted to do that last
mission again
uh and get that focused shield up that
was cool to like dodge bullets
yeah
all right this
i guess
yeah makes sense oh okay
someone is asking you to go back and
look in every single window to see if
there's any hidden things like that
little party there is not a chance in
hell there's something to do in that
room
based on how
dumb everyone was all right this is what
it is and then you go like this
do it
do it
touch it oh that was a cool ad though
not anymore
now it's this boring ass
runner
logo
what else
gotta spread the word guys spread the
word join the club viva la revolucion
join the club or gtfo
it's a pretty cool little shot here oh
those people
i would kill to go over there and beat
every one of those people up
someday well i mean look i mean
eventually you probably go over there oh
is that
looks like you'd have to cross the
street well this looks a little weird
so i'm thinking if you time it right you
can probably jump on a car and then from
there dude
well these aren't cars these are drones
with fans so maybe they chop my legs off
that's a drone yeah they're drones okay
some of these look a little weird i'm
thinking if you time it right you can
jump and hang on to the bottom of the
drone oh or like yeah pull off like an
obi-wan in episode two
okay i just didn't want to admit it
but what you're doing is suicide
um all right let's do one more and then
we'll call it um let's see here delivery
mission what's the closest one i got
looks like it's this one
that's a roundabout way to
quite the way oh
what do you think this way or this way
they look exactly the same don't they
could you fast travel
can you fast travel i think mary's are
you good
uh
i don't know where's my wait where's my
home base
your home base is
oh it was in
transit i don't know i'm cool with no
fast travel being honest
um okay well i guess we'll just get over
here why not all right let's do it this
one if we think it's closer though this
one with this oh jesus all right that
one's closer
this route looks a little bit more
intricate though all right think you're
ready for it oh yeah
wait
what
climb down the bolts down
there yeah
oh
wow oh man that would make your stomach
drop if you had vr
upsy daisies
i wonder what year it is
it's a good question
really this way
oh man i bet there's a
sweet
progression skill of like sliding down
rails you can only hope i hope so
sick
all right i'm in position i'll wait for
you here wait what how do you know what
i want faith where are you
what oh hey i am i starting a mission i
don't think so
i think they're just talking at you
faith is helping me out with something
no they totally they totally think i'm
doing this
all right you know what i'm let's just
do this then
the one that you're okay i think the
missions are more enjoyable to watch
anyway and then we'll call it after this
i mean the delivery is what you expect
it's just the same as dash point a to
point b i mean as simple as that
this one
whoa oh my hands my hands are
they're gone they're gone
climb thank you
is this right
am i going
i can't tell where to go jake
i don't know oh
no
where the hell i told me to come here
and this happened once or twice
uh
okay yeah it looks like you're going
around
all right
climb
do it
not climbing
that's weird yeah it's a little
weird
there you go it's like a running jump
thing
oh
do i climb up this
okay
these are these are terrifying yeah
do you have to hit a button to do that
yeah it's the same as jump okay it's
kind of like your main like
action oh yeah action button
oh more people
it's those same people what if they're
just they're like wearing sleeping masks
it's the same people they're everywhere
everyone's clowns
so they can't see you
look like us or die
oh yeah here we go
sick beanie whoa
let's do this
weird
um should we do this
okay let's do it all right so what's
happening
i heard you ran into gabriel krueger
word gets around
yeah look
progress are saying that they're going
to clamp down harder on the runners and
they're setting up those huge antennas
all over the city
someone should clamp down on them
great minds think alike i'm thinking
krugersec would be rather upset if
someone wrecked those antennas
and by someone you mean me hey i do it
myself but you were always the fighter
faith
sure
but let's keep noah out of this okay
no worries i'll keep a lookout from here
okay day
so you're doing the mission he's just
standing there
lazy ass
the youth man
whoa that was a
what up
yeah
oh no he's done
cool i want more funny fighting anyway
sick tight
yeah
i want to do another wall run oh
what someone's shooting me oh no what we
got guns
whoa dude
chill all right you're my number one man
come here
no
let's get him off yeah saying that
see ya see ya that's my trademark
all right you're going to go with your
bud
oh oh oh sick oh oh
oh
have you seen that before
only once before that's pretty cool uh i
want more of it though god that's fun to
watch
yeah weird i saw that in the beginning
of the tutorial and then i was like i
thought that was part of the game but
now you get more of it that was fun
see like more of this i don't know
more like visual
destroy it okay
oh damn
this seems dangerous
oh did we just damn
so i gotta get out this is where it's
this is what i'm doing it's a good way
to end the stream
so i bet those those are side quests
that are probably the same you know like
this is something you'll probably be
doing
a bunch of other times
this is cool i want to be chased
to live
row baby
get away from their scanners and they'll
lose you eventually see like here you
have to like drop
the first oh so i'm shooting me already
sounds like it
doing good though
got that momentum thanks jake
oh that'd be cool see there what
there that would be cool to do um oh
this is scary
oh framing
oh
easy peasy
cool that was the same that was that one
skill unlocked to like
see if you notice i i was trying to jump
over that railing but that that like
heater was right there so i
inadvertently grabbed onto it yeah that
would be the the coolest way to like
the lift your legs up uh skill what was
that oh yeah probably a lot i probably
unlock that now right now coil right
coil
oh you're damn right let's just quickly
see what that is because i'm really
curious
l1 l2
so you just landed on your ass
major tailbone
damage uh
okay so you would definitely want to
roll after right all right just this as
the same as usual all right try that
again just uh
whoa
cool you should uh end the stream by
doing coil off the side of the building
that's that's a good okay
i mean
all right
maybe not i don't know no no you're abs
you're on point let's do it over here
just can't make it get some speed going
all right i wanna i want to do it off of
railing right and just imagine
someone just watching it all right
well
thanks everyone for watching
yeah
you gotta limber up gotta limber up
before doing a move like this stretches
you know what
yo
that's gonna do it
fun stuff
cool well uh thanks everyone for
watching i hope you guys
got a nice look at mirror's edge
catalyst
uh we'll probably be or definitely be
having some more gameplay and content up
uh later today as well as um tomorrow
yeah um but uh yeah thanks for joining
me jake of course cool looking forward
to the game check out mary's uh mirror's
edge video too absolutely yeah um yeah
well stay tuned for next time guys
thanks so much
see you guys see ya
you